can tune in
so hopefully we are
live
on all things internet related with uh
my good old friend he's not that old but
he's a friend uh and that's Avi Loeb
joining us uh all the way from the
Eastern Seabourn Cambridge Massachusetts
Harvard and we have a new friend joining
us today also young and distinguished
and that's uh Professor Gary Nolan so
we've got three professors here on this
pre-thanksgiving uh day that uh is my
favorite holiday and I couldn't be more
grateful than to share it with uh such a
wonderful set of guests thank you guys
for joining me Gary how are you today up
north
great thank you and up north yes yes up
in The Frigid North of Palo Alto
and Avi is jealous of that frigidity I'm
sure Avi how are you sir I'm doing great
but most of the universe is much colder
than the earth so I I feel sympathy to
the rest of the universe oh that is
great well uh for those of you who are
new to this channel we have
conversations with the greatest
luminaries in science technology
engineering and math we have luminaries
ranging from 14 Nobel Prize winners uh
four billionaires and that includes Avi
and Gary so those are two new
billionaires uh we've had guests on from
all over the spectrum of culture and
today we're having a very special
pre-thanksgiving episode which is to
discuss and and have a a gentleman's
debate about the impact the import the
knowledge and the future of unexplained
aerial phenomena and this is an area
that these two gentlemen have made a
contribution I want to thank you guys in
particular because uh you know a lot of
what we do when we are expressing an
interest in this in this subject gets
met with derision with um maybe attempts
to humiliate to just to discredit folks
that are interested I find that uh
repugnant but uh but the fact is you
guys are some of the most distinguished
intellects on this planet we're very
lucky to to have you in this community
but you're also incredibly open-minded
so I don't expect you to reply to that
uh but I just want to I do have a reply
I just wanted to mention that in
politics you see it very often that
there is polarization where you have the
extremes on both ends uh fueling each
other because one side this says sort of
nonsense and then the other side uses it
this fuel to say also nonsense and then
you end up in a situation that doesn't
make much sense and uh the middle ground
of Common Sense is not populated not in
politics these days and I would say not
in Academia and uh also on this question
of unidentified objects because what I
realized is first of all you know as an
astronomer I was driven into it by data
that the implied an object that looks
really unusual and that what happened to
be the first object from outside the
solar system that we identified called
the moon wine since then we find two
others before it meteors with my student
we can talk about it yeah but the point
is this looked unusual they didn't look
familiar so I said okay let's study them
and of course the subject was ridiculed
by mainstream astronomers and then they
tried to explain those things in terms
of rocks that we had never seen before
objects that we'd never so to me I mean
it didn't sound like they are trying to
use familiar objects to explain them but
they appealed to unfamiliar objects that
still keep them sort of relaxed that
they are natural and so forth so they
dismissed any possible association with
other technological civilizations even
though we ourselves launched five probes
to Interstellar space and you know why
not imagine that others did it as well
billions of years before us and then on
the other hand you have those believers
who would interpret anything unusual in
the sky in terms of being
extraterrestrial and the reason I say
that is you know when Ukrainian
astronomers reported about some dark
objects and didn't have good distance
estimates for those and I suggested that
maybe they got the distance wrong and as
a result this would be just artillery
shells uh those Believers jumped at me
and said you know it must be
extraterrestrial because there could be
new physics and I say well for new
physics you really need a very high bar
you know like we work really hard we you
need Exquisite data to convince you that
you are missing something in the known
physics and you can't just jump into a
conclusion about new physics because you
know you see something that you didn't
really measure well okay if it's sloppy
data that cannot be justification for
new physics you need to have exquisite
easy data to argue for so you see this
polarization of two sides and one uses
the other to justify their extreme
positions so the scientists say we don't
want to be to share the same bed with
those people that don't believe in the
scientific method and those that don't
you know those Believers on the other
hand say look at the scientists they
don't pay attention to this so my point
is populating the middle ground that
makes common sense and following the
scientific method is unpopular okay and
that is really surprising to me I
thought it's only the realm of politics
but over the past year I learned that
it's the realm of science as well in
some areas yeah and we've we've talked
before about new physics but today we're
going to talk about new biology and
that's courtesy of our of our new guest
on the show which is uh which is a real
treat Gary Nolan uh you're perhaps you
know along with Avi my most frequently
requested guest on this subject and I
just want to introduce you to my
audience you know most of the Nobel
laureates I've had on are physicists
although I have had on a Stanford
Professor Guido imbenz who's a colleague
on campus and I have Jay bhattacharya
not a Nobel Prize winner yet but he's
coming on next let's talk about his
experiences with the galileo-like affair
that we'll talk about when he's on but
Gary's an immunologist an academic and
inventor business executive helps to uh
to to lead or works with six different
companies he holds the Ratchford and
Carolina a Harris Professor endowed
chair and the department of pathology at
Stanford University School of Medicine
usually Gary and Avi knows this I
usually ask you to start off by
describing your latest book but you told
me uh you prefer papers and uh and I
want to I just get a quick tease of this
upcoming paper if you're allowed to to
talk about it just from to set the stage
in your Bona fides for my physics-minded
audience
oh we've got well let me first riff off
of something that uh Avi was just saying
about this you know this divide and you
know I think a lot of it begins with
something that I've always focused on
especially in my lab meetings is finding
the point which is off the the line and
paying attention to it and not ignoring
it because you can continue to walk that
line and continue to basically do
conventional science but it's when you
see the point off the line and you try
to explain it either as being an error
or as something that is indicative of
either new biology or new physics or new
observations Etc you know I and I think
I'm gonna I've been having this
conversation with a fair number of
people lately about you know what is a
standard of proof and you know the
standard of proof really differs
depending upon who you are you know
science has a standard of proof that
says you know I I can reproduce it
I can hand it the data to you you know I
it's not an anecdote I mean I have my
own anecdotes of things that I've
observed that you know in standard
science might be thought of as
preliminary data it's preliminary data
it's sufficient for me to get
sufficiently interested but it is not
something that I could hand to somebody
else and say here is proof of a new
object or a new physics or what have you
so I think we I think one of the things
that is important for both I think what
Avi is doing what I'm doing is to teach
the lay public
what these different kinds of proof
structures are that enable one to be
thought of as say a Believer or to be
thought of as a scientist now a Believer
isn't a negative thing I mean religions
are believers but there is if you want
to take the realm of religion and belief
and hand it over to science that's where
this disparity happens so I'm I'm happy
to occupy that middle ground where Avi
is basically arguing we should be as
scientists and argue to the people on my
let's say far science extreme and say
you know what you guys are acting more
like priests than you are like
scientists
uh so why don't you come a little bit
closer to this line and then you say the
people on the far other side you're
acting more like you know you're not act
you're acting more like priests and if
you want to talk to the scientists you
need to come to the middle and so let's
find a way to to create languages which
allow the two sides to talk to each
other that said I'm not you know this is
not the U.N
I'm completely willing to ignore both
sides just do the work
create the data publish a paper get it
peer reviewed and say there it is now
you try to argue with the data that I've
just presented you and if you can't come
up with a different conclusion that
justifies the data and at least the
speculations I'm coming up with then get
out of here
yeah so Brian if I may just add yeah go
ahead Abby two short points one there is
a Common Thread between spirituality
and the frontiers of Science in both
cases you are exploring the unknown
and we should be humble in the sense of
not assuming we know the answer in
advance you know a lot of scientists do
their job in order to demonstrate that
they are smart it's all about themselves
you know they will do mathematical
gymnastics even if the real Universe
didn't show that there are more than
three special dimensions they will just
show that they are smart for 50 years by
doing manipulations in extra Dimensions
even though we have no clue for that now
I say okay five years ten years
reasonable 50 years is starting to be
excessive and the point is it's not
about us not the most you know showing
off it's about learning about nature and
unless you get some dialogue with nature
getting some evidence what you're doing
you're doing math mathematics okay and
you are trying to show off but you're
not explaining nature so that's a first
thing first thing is we need humility to
learn from nature by experiments to get
the feedback and respect the data
whatever it is if it looks unusual we
should not brag that we know everything
in advance that we we are experts that
we can explain everything by past
knowledge we should be open-minded to
new knowledge the second point that you
know that is really important is that
science is about the signal to noise
ratio yes okay what does it mean there
are all the time noisy you know
fluctuations things that happen by
chance that do not signify anything
unusual it's just rare phenomena that
happened now and then okay and what
people fail to understand like in a war
zone if you go to Ukraine you increase
the level of Noise Okay that's why I was
reluctant to consider Ukraine because
there is a there are lots of things
flying in the sky many of which we don't
know because the US government wants it
to be classified or the Europeans want
it to be classified or the Russians
wanted to but there are things flying in
the sky all the time this is in
increases the level of noise in the
sense that we don't know what they are
okay and there would be spy satellites
all kinds of things you have to realize
that given that the noise level is high
the chance of you seeing something that
you don't understand is higher okay so
it's all about how significant is the
signal that you detect relative to
things that happen by chance in the
environment that you're looking at and
that's something that the public fails
to follow because they say we will go to
the war zone because maybe they will be
there but then you have to understand
that that burden of proof is actually
higher it's higher if you are in a noisy
environment you have to work harder to
demonstrate that there is something
unusual going on and you know that very
well from the cosmic microwave
background from studies of the Union I
mean we looked for fluctuations in the
cosmic micro background Relic from The
Big Bang for many decades until the
signal to noise ratio per pixel was
above one at that point it was detected
and before that it was not so it's
really all about the not just the signal
but how unusual is the signal relative
to some run random occurrences in the
environment that you're looking at yeah
I think that's a that's often missed out
and and one of the things that I most
frequently hear about is that uh there's
you know kind of a conflation of the of
the notion that these are legitimate
phenomena to study but also that they
could be representative of much more
plausible I mean effectively much more
plausible uh explanations they could be
um you know hallucinations or mass
delusions they could be military psyops
there could so do you guys think that a
lot of the kind of um dereliction or the
uh or or the denigration of this subject
Gary I'm interested particularly to get
to to get your take on it because you've
been incredibly courageous and uh it's
almost like when you talk about it
you're immediately assumed that you must
cleave to one camp or the other so I
want to ask you in in keeping with the
Avi said do you did you come into this
field I mean this is not your field
you're an eminent world renowned
scientist uh did you come into this
field with any preconceived notions that
there were phenomena and then so so
there's been a great sacrifice that you
and Avi to some extent have have
undertaken so explain what was your
motivation how did you what's your
origin story in this uh well I mean I I
mean I have two Origin stories if you
will I mean I I've been open about this
I mean I saw an object when I was young
as a as a paper boy uh and it went right
over my head it was you know it was un
uh unmistakable uh you know that it was
not supposed to be there but I was what
I think it was 11 or 12 years old I
don't really remember
um but I didn't know what it was but I
remembered it years later
so that when the whole subject of what
UFOs or whatnot might be I could look
back on that and say well you know
insofar as what everybody else is
claiming this to be that was a UFO it
was clearly it to me it looked like
technology it had lights uh it was
making no noise it was 30 feet over my
head uh and it was you know 5 30ish in
the morning
um but you know as I've explained this
through to
um Avi at one point uh it's an anecdote
and so it is it is not sufficient for me
to use that as proof of anything except
to myself to me it it currently
motivates me to continue to look into
this because at some level I want to
prove not only to myself that I wasn't
seeing something uh but I want to prove
to others that it's it's worth it but I
got you know I I got brought into it uh
by basically a visit by government
agencies and an aerospace Corporation
asking me to help them understand how uh
pilots and intelligence Personnel or how
they had been harmed and they you know
they came to me because
um my lab had developed or been involved
in developing uh one of the world's most
advanced blood analysis uh instruments
and they said okay well in the in part
of a larger medical workup on these
individuals I said would you please help
us look at the blood of these
individuals to look for signs of
inflammatory disorders uh and they
showed me data and that data was
sufficient for me to get more and more
interested in this and then I got you
know shown additional and more data and
frankly it was just like I was saying
before it was data off the line and that
in just it I'm just drawn to that kind
of stuff I mean it is one of those kinds
of unsolvable problems that are or just
was begging for an answer and I suppose
the reason why I continue to get more
involved is because people told me not
to get involved like other Sciences oh
you shouldn't be doing this it'll ruin
your career and I just it just I had a
an inner Welling I guess of anger about
it
why would you even say that you're it
seems like you're closing your mind to
some fascinating possibilities and
anyway it's my time so why do you care
right right I think that's the you know
kind of the the the you know to whatever
extent there is a conspiracy and I'm not
a conspiracy-minded person I don't think
you guys are either but there is a a
desire not to think about these things I
mean Avi mentioned religion earlier
um you know one of the reasons there's a
conspiracy there's a conspiracy by
scientists to tell you to not think
about it which isn't like it's being
driven by anybody behind the scenes
right it's like this it's like this uh I
don't know it's like they're afraid of
being painted with a brush of your
belief even though I'm not asking them
to believe in it
who says look you guys are I mean
they're gonna bring out this card you
guys are three chaired white male
professors you are the peak of privilege
blah blah blah
um how could you legitimately say Avi
that you're there's a conspiracy against
you you're one of the most yeah Peak
performers the planet has ever known I
mean how do you answer those kind of
critiques well there is no conspiracy I
don't believe in those but I wanted to
mention that two-thirds of the America
of all Americans believe that there is
extraterrestrial life
um and uh that's more than the number
you know the the nearly 50 percent that
believe God exists okay so and then
there was a poll recently uh by
Elizabeth stanway in the UK she pulled
the of all the 350 astronomers and 94 of
them admitted that they uh were
fascinated with science fiction and and
then 60 something percent of them are
suggested that they chose a song me as a
result of reading science fiction and
um you know thinking about the
Extraterrestrial intelligence so I say
to myself well it must you know resonate
very deeply with those astronomers and
with the general public the only
question is why professionally they put
this makeup of pretending they don't
care about it they don't want to fund it
and they want to assume that the
universe is a zeroth uh assumption that
the universe is dead lifeless which is
pretty much what cosmologists do all the
time and you know I I do believe that
unidentified aerial phenomena are a
mixed bag I think many of them are
probably used for Espionage but by other
nations uh I think that some of them are
just weather balloons or
um you know drones or U.S government
developing some equipment that others
are not aware of or you know it could be
some you know natural phenomena like
birds or or thunderstorms or whatever or
meteors but it's sufficient to have one
object which originated from an
extraterrestrial origin for this to
change the future of humanity because
imagine us finding a gadget and you know
the chance that the gadget was produced
by civilization which is exactly at the
same technological phase as we are is
minute because we developed our Science
and Technology over one century quantum
mechanics was discovered a hundred years
ago and all of our gadgets are based on
that understanding of quantum mechanics
just 100 years my my point is that's one
part in 100 million of the age of the
universe so most like and most stars
formed five billion years before the Sun
so most likely they are much more
advanced than we are whoever produced
this gadget and we can learn a lot it uh
you know and and one thing we need not
to worry about that's something that
Stephen Hawking argued that you know we
should be really careful they might harm
us I don't think so I think there's so
much Superior to us it's just like a
biker you know driving down the sidewalk
and what the colony of ants does in the
crack of the pavement is completely
irrelevant I mean they can decide about
the protocol how to engage with the
biker but that doesn't really matter so
I think we are dealing with something
far beyond us which in a way you know is
uh similar to religions that believe in
in something much more powerful so I
that's why I said that spirituality and
the frontiers of science may have
something in common well let me you know
since you've heard my HBO a little bit
Avi but maybe Gary hasn't
um you know I of the three of us might
be you know I mean I think we're all
skeptical I think that's the job of a
scientist to be skeptical but also
approach things with an open mind and
maybe the latter is not as common as the
former should be and the default
reaction of a scientist you know should
be essentially as Isaac Asimov said you
know that's odd not like Eureka I have
found it
um but I've said to you I've said you
know the well first of all the the
appeal to popularity right so I was in
Europe recently at Galileo's house I
mean this is amazing I was at Galileo's
prison house in Florence in our tetri
and uh and I was there and I was
thinking you know what the prison bars
on there that he was imprisoned for
saying something essentially that was
that was true and that didn't go against
the prevailing religious doctrine of the
day in other words uh the the person who
came up with the idea that the Earth was
the center of the universe wasn't you
know Jesus Christ it was Aristotle and
Ptolemy now you guys know better than
than the average person those are pagans
right so why did the Catholic Church Avi
did you know this that the Catholic
Church uh you know made Aristotle
effectively baptized him a thousand four
hundred years after him so that the G so
that the sun could not be the center of
the universe I mean you can understand
it from a political point of view
because if people uh if you flutter the
Eagles of people they adopt your
Doctrine so in order to attract more
Believers what you would argue is that
we are Central to the universe where
central actors God is really focused on
us and then people will believe you if
you say oh you we are just side actors
you know there are much more important
things happening in the universe and we
are just we happen to be here by chance
and then people say well you are just
depressing you know like this Doctrine
is not appealing to me I want to be at
the center like all the alpha males want
to be at the center and guess what if
you were to tell Putin that by
conquering a piece of land he would look
like an ant hugging a single grain of
sand on the landscape of a huge beach
you know he would be really upset but
that's the truth you know the universe
is huge we are insignificant we just
came at the end if you come at the end
to a play and you are not at the center
of the stage guess what the play is not
about you but people don't like that
message they want to be Central and
important they want God to look over
their shoulder and re respond to
everything they do and as a result if
the church adopts this doctrine that we
are Central to the universe they get
more Believers so I think it was serving
a very good political purpose well that
that brings me to uh to a question for
Gary so that that one of my friends here
in San Diego wanted me to ask you why
should we expect along the lines of what
Avi said the centrality this notion that
our Cosmic ego and significance why
would we expect or should we expect that
aliens would even have DNA or or or have
any kind of chemical composition like we
are is that something that we would AB
initio expect in other words is DNA the
fundamental operating system of life in
the universe uh or would we are we being
too
um what do you say anthropocentric by
assuming that if there are life forms
that they must be quote unquote like us
well I think you can you can take that
question in two directions I mean one
there's plenty of evidence that the raw
materials for DNA are everywhere
um that's pretty clear
um there's some there's two interesting
papers that I'm aware of about uh about
sort of the uh the panspermia
um notion uh one of them is it's sort of
applying Moore's law to DNA uh
regulatory complexity and the the
regulatory programs that uh you can
infer uh from everything from you know
viruses through bacteria yeast up until
us and the the premise is that you can
essentially show that there is a Moore's
Law of genetic complexity that uh would
uh you can draw across the timeline of
um life on Earth
the problem with the timeline and the
Moore's complexity is that it goes It
goes back and points to a a time about 8
billion years ago when life likely uh
exists or started in terms of if it were
a linear line now you so there's two
solutions to that it either happened
eight billion years ago well before our
uh our solar system was around and got
here on meteorites or uh other uh
basically modalities or it rapidly
ascended and the complexity basically
happened in maybe 100 million years and
then achieved linearity
um so that's that's one fascinating uh
aspect and it's an interesting published
paper people can go to argue about the
math if they want I'm not going to get
into the that art you know the authors
of that Gary so I can put in the text
um I'll I'll go find it for you and I
haven't got it on on my computer here
but um I'll put it in later it's a
Moore's Law
um argument about it's fascinating and
the other is the so-called it's called
the wow signal in the in the genetic
code
and it was by a couple of uh scientists
from I think it was Azerbaijan
mathematicians looking at the at the the
genetic code structure and essentially
laying out again a mathematical argument
that the DNA code the genetic code for
determining a triplet of bases into into
proteins was designed
right and so they said that basically
that's the wow signal that we're all
looking for now again I mean the the
problem I mean it's a fascinating
argument and the math looks good uh but
um the problem is it falls prey to the
uh to the uh
the attack that you you you can't apply
simple linear mathematical approaches to
Evolution it's the same thing that you
know the uh the selfish Gene of Richard
Dawkins his beautiful book
um basically lays out that you know just
because the eye didn't ebenezio uh
evolve out of nothing it doesn't mean
that there's a God involved but the wow
signal it's a it's a beautiful it really
is a beautiful paper it's a pink piece I
posted it in the in the uh it's overlaid
your face right now but uh I see it
there yeah no no it's great
um and you know I just again I I don't
think it's proof of anything Kazakhstan
not Azerbaijan I apologize to those
Nations don't start any wars in that
part of the world please Gary yeah but I
think that those are those are two
papers that
um
underpin the sort of scientific notion
that this panspermia effect can be at
least analyzed by traditional approaches
mathematics at the least but then the
other is you know I think you go back
and and probably Avi knows this as uh
even better the so-called notion of the
boltzmann brains right are you aware of
this Brian the pulseman brain yeah yes
we spoke with Sean Carroll about that
and uh yeah I mean it's fascinating that
you know you you can perhaps have
organized plasma or organized objects in
3D space that if they could be uh if
they could self-contain themselves
there's no reason that they cannot be
conscious right it's not life as we
understand it but you can still imagine
it as conscious our Consciousness and
you know if if such existed it's been
around since the beginning of of what we
would call time
yeah if I may add that Brian uh what
traditionally humans called God in
religious texts in philosophical texts
you know there is a lot of philosophy
around it
could simply
be attributed to an advanced scientific
civilization because we are getting to
the point where we will uh develop life
in our Laboratories and you can and
again it's a hundred years after modern
science started so you can imagine that
a civilization that had a million years
of scientific work might know how to
unify quantum mechanics and gravity even
though for 50 years string theories were
not really able to come up with
predictions maybe a more advanced
civilization was able to figure out how
to unify quantum mechanics and and
gravity and and engineer that knowledge
okay so once you understand it you can
engineer it and create perhaps a baby
Universe in the laboratory and so my
point is that here is a path it's often
thought that religion and science are
somewhat contradictory but that's if you
stick to traditional Notions but it
could well be that you know when you
advance to a high enough level of
intelligence
you realize that what we called God is
actually a manifestation and of a much
higher level of intelligence or
scientific development and that's where
I think that we can bring philosophy
religion and science together it's not
necessarily contradictory let's just but
for that we need to be open-minded
uh we need to allow uh when we attend
the class of intelligent civilizations
allow for a smarter student in the class
not just say we are the smartest there
is nobody else in the in the room but
rather say let's check okay because that
was the biggest shock my daughters had
when I brought brought them on the first
day to kindergarten they realized there
is a smarter kid around you know like
that is a shock and a lot of people
prefer not to look and say we are the
only ones in class and we are so smart
that nobody else exists out there and I
say well you know you'll be behave just
like those people who put gorilla in
house arrest because they didn't want to
learn about something new
let's let's go back to the panspermia
but by the way this I can't resist that
uh on my channel I like to give away
stuff and one of the things I give away
are meteorites uh here are some
meteorites uh and uh Gary brought it up
of course and and I can't resist so you
can actually win your own meteorite if
you go to my mailing list Brian
keating.com list and you'll be entered
to win a drawing of a real genuine
meteorite that crashed into Argentina
about 5 000 years ago was discovered in
the 1500s and was used for tools and and
other sorts of implements and and it's
really fun and I'll send that to you I
may even send one lucky winner some uh
Uranus soap because you need to keep
your anus clean as we all know uh but
but uh but actually my point is a
serious one so
panspermia works both ways right so I
want to ask both of you guys
um maybe starting with Gary
panspermia should work the opposite way
in other words life on Earth should have
disseminated throughout the uh
throughout our solar system and over the
billions of years you were absolutely
right uh the origin of life you know
better than me we believe started about
4 billion years ago in other words it's
just a few hundred million years after
this meteorite uh was created in the
same proto-solar system right the fact
is we don't observe any evidence for
life in our solar system I'm not saying
it's dispositive as I think Carl Sagan
said uh you know lack of evidence is not
evidence of lack uh and you know there's
my favorite finger puppet of Carl Sagan
I've got all sorts of props I'm a prop
Cosmic uh prop Cosmic uh but I want to
ask you Gary to what extent can we use
in a Bayesian framework the lack of
observation of any trace of any
existence of life on a meteorite on on
another planet as some constraint on the
facundity argument that life should be
ubiquitous once it gets so I I don't
think that the Bayesian framework
operates here in two for two reasons one
we haven't done the real test first of
all I mean so we sent uh I mean actually
the department that I got my PhD in here
at Stanford the genetics department
um they actually built the experiments
uh that were done on Mars and the Viking
Landers uh and you know there was
there's actually been a lot of post-hoc
analysis of that original data that said
you know what this actually probably was
evidence of life but
um strangely and I don't understand this
I'm not saying that it's a conspiracy or
anything they they keep sending back
microscopes that look at rocks but they
don't send back a growth Media or
anything to try to see if something if
they were to drop a piece some dirt from
Martian soil in it if if any Critters
grow bacteria or what have you so you
know so first of all the experiment has
been done so you can't populate the
priors in the Bayesian inference uh
there
um second well Venus at least from the
you know Viewpoint of
um the kind of life that we would be
looking for is is not a not a nice place
to be if you're if you're life but you
know I mean I think we're all looking at
the at the Under Ice oceans around the
larger planets here and I would I would
bet any amount of money that we're gonna
find something under there I mean all
the necessary requirements for the kind
of life that we think of are going to be
there
um water heat uh and probably things
like hydrogen sulfide or other redox
related chemicals that would be
sufficient for growing let's say the
even primitive life will will be there I
I'm 100 sure but that's where it's going
to be here is an interesting anecdote
let me just mention that
um you know if there was a news media
back two and a half billion years ago
they would say some good news and some
bad news about life in the solar system
because what happened was that Mars lost
its atmosphere around that time
and it used to have liquid water on the
surface it's pretty obvious based on all
the data we have from the perseverance
Rover more most recently so there was
clearly there were clearly lakes and
eventually for some mysterious reason uh
Mars lost its atmosphere I mean it it uh
it has a much lower gravity than the
earth but there was some event that
caused it to lose its atmosphere and as
a result all liquid water on its surface
all life form so we might find evidence
that life existed on early Mars because
it was not very different from Earth
early Earth now around the same time two
and a half billion years that's a
complete it could be a complete
coincidence or maybe not but the oxygen
level in the atmosphere of Earth Rose
abruptly we don't know why I mean we
know what produced the oxygen
cyanobacteria but we don't know why
there was this sudden rise in the oxygen
level and that of course enabled all the
chemistry that allowed complex life
forms like ourselves to exist okay
without that we wouldn't exist there
wasn't much oxygen in the first half of
the life of the earth and both both
events occurred at the same time there
was bad news on Mars good news on Earth
for intelligent life or complex life and
maybe they were related I don't know but
when we look at other planets one thing
to keep in mind is you know that we have
a 50 chance to conclude the to conclude
that life exists if there is oxygen
because there was microbial life on
Earth for half of its life without much
oxygen in the atmosphere and the second
is that within a billion years from now
the sun will boil off all the oceans on
Earth okay so even Earth will lose its
atmosphere and the water on its surface
and that's one billion years from now so
that's like 20 percent left you know we
don't have much time left anyway and all
the tricks were doing about global
climate change and so forth you know it
wouldn't change much when the sun will
heat up the surface of the Earth good
thing we have tenure most stars like how
do we have 10 years right but one thing
to keep in mind most stars like the sun
formed five billion years before the Sun
so they already went through that now we
didn't hear the cries for help from
those civilizations that were on these
habitable planets like the Earth and
said ah we are losing our you know
atmosphere we are losing our oceans
we're losing everything and we and they
cried for help there must have been sort
of a a an immediate Exodus they must
have sent lots of spacecraft in fact
most of the interstellar objects most of
the interstellar crafts may have been
launched at this last phase when the
civilizations that were highly evolved
technologically realize we're about to
die okay so they sent everything as much
as they can and so most of the things we
find in the interstate I mean it may be
relics from that desperation but we
couldn't hear them because we were not
around and you know these radio signals
passed by the earth when microbes were
around we were not there to hear them
and we will go through that in a billion
years uh if we are if we will survive
all the other catastrophes but my point
is that's something to keep in mind when
we look for seti Sigma radio signals you
know they cannot come from a star that
evolved into the red giant phase you
know like most of the sun-like Stars
went through that and therefore just
forget about it um well I guess you know
the my point in bringing this up is that
you know you I either have two different
uh conjectures one is that the day after
we discover unequivocal evidence for the
existence of life outside of the earth
that will transform everything and I I
sometimes feel like that stands in
direct Contra distinction to the fact
pattern that we've already seen and
that's the following in 1996 late 1996
early 1997. President Bill Clinton stood
on the White House lawn and announced
the discovery of meteorites not unlike
this uh in Antarctica where I've been
twice and I've spent about a month of my
life there and uh it's a Barren place
it's a frozen dead continent uh just
like the ice Planet Hoth
um I I love the people there but I
wouldn't want to live there right uh now
that was never falsified in fact there
were in order to get a NASA press
conference on the White House lawn it
had to be peer reviewed right Avi uh and
and that peer review process took place
and it's never been anti-peer reviewed
it's never been retracted formally and
my question to you guys is wait what was
the what was the results
you discovered these meteorites uh from
the Allen lands hell meteorite fall I
was actually discovered and it was
believed to either contain microbial
life oh yes okay yeah right and that was
and you could see it in the movie
contact there's a scene where President
Clinton is talking and Jody Foster's on
and uh and that's really real it's not
cheesy guy he actually did that and they
used the actual NASA press conference so
my point is that we already in the
general public has already been through
this they don't know it's been retracted
I mean I meet people all the time that
don't know my bicep 2 paper was you know
the conclusions were retracted and Avi
knows that story very well because he
was there uh but I want to ask you guys
a question Gary if the general public
you know really hasn't gotten up in arms
about this discovery which in their
minds is still valid it's still a actual
scientific covered what makes us think
that if you come up with proof or Avi
comes up with some discovery that
anything will be different 20 years from
now
well you know I I said this before I
think if it doesn't affect kitchen table
issues um or doesn't challenge
somebody's religion uh or their status
in the in the world they probably will
just ignore it
um until it I I think eeks out in and
leaks out into into the general
scientific framework so that it becomes
as of many things uh it now is an
accepted fact and two years ago it it
wasn't so I
I I mean I'm
I'm perfectly fine with the public not
agreeing with the conclusions or any
conclusions at any point in time I'm
only I'm only interested in convincing a
sufficient Cadre of scientists uh that
something is worth studying uh so that
you know continued research can be done
on it I mean you know I was I often say
I was I was raised Catholic but brought
up Jewish uh by uh two fantastic
scientist mentors when I was a graduate
student here at Stanford Leonard and and
Leonard herzenberg and Lee herzenberg
the the wife was always of the when I
asked a certain question says Gary
you're asking a question that is yes or
no and you can that's sort of a Las
Vegas question you can be spending so
much of your time uh on a no and you've
wasted you know as many months or years
of your life as possible sometimes it's
easy enough to just switch the mode of
the question around so that it's a Zen
outcome uh so that no matter what the
answer is it's interesting and so I
think that this is one of those kinds of
questions this whole subject matter it
doesn't matter what the answer is if
it's if it's no it's maybe disappointing
but that's still interesting because
that means life on on Earth is unique
but if it's yes uh if it's yes that
there is life even in our own solar
system doesn't prove There Are UFOs or
Europeans but it is at least a step in
the direction of saying well it could
have been I'm convinced that no matter
what we find on mars or under the oceans
of Titan or what have you are is going
to be you know is going to be related to
us whether it started there and came
here or vice versa I don't really
necessarily care but there are actually
genetic ways to to get at that probably
by the way uh Brian I should emphasize
to me science is about learning I mean
it's a learning experience about reality
okay so uh nature is educating us and we
better pay attention it's a dialogue
with nature it's not a monologue okay
and very often we get into a monologue
which is a very bad
attitude when you date with a partner
right you need to to listen to the other
side and that's why experiments are so
important okay now the point is why is
it beneficial to us to listen and figure
out what reality is is because we it
allows us to adapt to it if we have the
wrong ideas if we live in the metaverse
and put goggles on our head and believe
that we look like Brad Pitt all day long
and that we are very attractive next to
celebrities you know we may feel good
about ourselves but it will not be the
reality that we all share and the same
if you take recreational drugs you may
feel high and very good and but it's not
the reality that now the scientific
inquiry allows us to figure out what
reality is and sometimes it contradicts
our uh you know prior beliefs like
quantum mechanics you know it was in
conflict with the traditional thinking
and Einstein had a problem with that but
he was wrong okay so the point of the
matter is that by understanding why you
are wrong you can then and realize how
to cope with the new sense of reality so
for example if you know that the Earth
moves around the sun when you design a
space mission you take that into account
if you believe very decisively that the
sun moves around the earth you will
never get to your destination by
launching a rocket okay because you have
the wrong idea so reality is whatever it
is and we better adapt to it and the
only way to do that is by you know
collecting data not human beings are not
scientific sensors they're not
scientific tools we learn that over
history that's why we we are using
instruments and that's what Science is
based on so collecting quantitative data
understanding your instruments and then
learning something new about reality
will benefit us no matter what we find
absolutely and I wonder Gary what do you
attribute and and I think you know just
with with all lack of false sincerity to
mix a lot of things I think you in
particular have been in part uh crucial
in destigmatization of the this
phenomena and to the fact now that it's
being studied by none other than NASA
what do you attribute the recent upsurge
the kind of you know the three of us are
old enough maybe to remember Nancy
Kerrigan uh why me you know why now why
is this becoming in the in the Forefront
of our Collective you know frontal lobe
why is it not the Avi lobe uh why is it
uh why is it now coming to the Forefront
such that what was previously derided
and you have suffered a lot of slings
and arrows personally Gary why is it now
coming sort of kosher to to investigate
this so much so that NASA itself is
investigating it what do you attribute
that to
well I I think it's a conversation
across the multiple fields of let's say
human professional uh uh Arenas I mean
one is the Sciences
um you know it was for me actually very
exciting when
um Avi got on board because I felt like
okay well here's another person uh
another serious scientist uh that I can
point to and say so yeah I'm not the
only I'm not the only one
um but I second you know I think it was
really the efforts of people in the
intelligence Services I mean we all know
of Lou Elizondo and Chris Mellon and
then the pilots who came forward and not
because I think that they're they were
addressing some sort of conspiracy they
were actually being scientists
they were saying look there's there's
data off the curve here that needs to be
understood we don't know what it is
and I think them going public and going
I mean everything even though the the
New York Times article changed things in
the back in 2017 I think those Pilots
being on 60 Minutes it was that kind of
personal uh frankly anecdote uh that was
you know given and conveyed by
um by credible individuals uh that
changed things because you you heard
people speaking in their own terms I
mean I can speak to another scientist in
my own terms within my own language of
Science and they will believe me because
of that so there was something
essentially very human about what these
individuals did where they they took
more bricks and arrows than than I ever
did
um and and so I think that it was it's
that kind of back and forth there's a
there's a Ricochet effect occurring
um where I don't think we can expect
that Ricochet to be sufficient to propel
it I think we need to continue to work
on it and frankly we need to I need to
be able to provide the kind of proof
that I think another scientist would
agree with me is is irrefutable and I've
had obviously I think that's kind of
what it's about last year I had on um
Jim semivan you know former CIA
um
operative executive maybe along with Tom
Delong with my good friend Kurt J mungle
who may be listening his YouTube channel
theories of everything everyone should
subscribe to that uh conversate and
actually thank you Kurt for putting me
in touch with Gary I have to get
when I talk about uh these these
subjects with Tom Delong he mentioned a
problem that he has but he's not a
scientist so he could get away with it
and that was that he claimed to have
alien technology an artifact from a
downed uh Craft
um and he claims that it's 100 genuine
however the means by which he acquired
it cannot be either divulged or
reproduced in other words there's a
chain of custody problem that Avi and I
don't suffer from right if Avi and I
look at a uh at a muon uh their muons
are like Commodities they're fungible
one meal you've seen one meon you've
seen them all
um they're they're interchangeable uh
but but alien craft aren't and so
therefore it's very important the
provenance so to speak and I and I guess
I'm wondering you know from your
excursions what do you make of of the
claims of Tom de long or a Jacques valet
who I know you've worked with well if
he's if he's talking about the uh the
so-called magnesium Museum bismuth
metamaterial you know I I have pieces of
that uh
uh and I don't think that there is
sufficient evidence at this point to
claim that is clearly uh you know from
an extraterrestrial vehicle
um that said I don't think that
sufficient analysis has has been done on
it it does have slightly altered
magnesium ratios I've I've looked at
that myself but they're not so far off
that they that they can't be construed
as some other sort of reason for you
know in the in the making of it so I'm
unless he's talking about something else
I I don't I don't know and nor have I
seen it uh the the evidence and so it's
I I put it into the into the anecdote
category and I like Tom I mean I'm I I'm
a yeah you know he's a friend uh but I I
haven't seen anything else now I have
been given uh pieces of material that do
have chains of evidence this is the
so-called ubatuba event where we did do
a very detailed uh analysis is using
secondary iron Mass Spec of the isotope
ratios of two pieces one was com and we
did it in the same instrument at the
same time under the same vacuum
conditions uh one piece was perfectly
conventional uh magnesium ratios the
other were way off I mean so far off as
to be the only thing that I could
imagine is it was manufactured now that
doesn't prove it's a UAP that doesn't
prove it was alien it just says to me
somebody back in the 70s spent a lot of
money to change the isotope ratios and
then blew it up over a beach in Brazil
and so the only question it raises to me
is who would do that and why would they
do it right I mean because we don't use
Isotopes or anything other than either
medical reasons or blowing stuff up
so so if I may add that Brian so
um given the landscape that I described
before of scientists being skeptical and
then Believers being very
um proactive in um so forth given that
you would ask yourself okay who would be
the first to notice something unusual
it's obviously the government
who has the day job of worrying about
National Security because they have to
monitor the sky at all times and you
know protect military personnel so they
keep patrolling or looking from above
from satellites
on Earth and if there is anything
unusual they would be the first to
notice it because the astronomers build
telescopes that focus on a small region
of the sky look at very distant sources
and if something flies above their
telescope they dismiss it and even if
they see an object from Interstellar
space that looks unusual they would say
oh it's a rock of a type that we've
never seen before so you can see that by
the way an anecdote a colleague of mine
wrote a review paper in annual reviews
of astronomy and astrophysics about
omuamua the first reported Interstellar
object and he said I just finished
writing it a review about the comet
omuamua and I said what do you mean the
comet we all know that there was no
cometary tale detected and in fact the
speechless Space Telescope looked very
deeply couldn't see any traces of carbon
based molecules so he said well I have a
theory that in fact this object had a
cometary tale when we didn't look at it
and didn't have a commentary tale when
we looked at it so I said that's just
like going to the zoo and looking at an
elephant and saying the elephant is a
zebra it's just that the stripes show up
when you don't look at it at the
elephant and just think about it
mainstream astronomer writing the
authoritative review on and on object
that looked unusual and calls it
something that is inappropriate like a
comment why would he do that first he
has the backing of people that say oh
it's natural forget about it second he
wants to have the Cozy warm feeling of
something familiar okay so when you call
it a comet you feel okay we can move on
now my point is this this is not
supposed to be the way science is done
we are all supposed to be kids wondering
about the world without pretensions
without pretending that we are experts
that we know everything and without
bullying any opinion that might be
different than ours that is the way
science should be done and here I see a
problem because when young scholars see
this Behavior they hesitate to innovate
and then science is not progressing at
the same rate as it should it should be
blue sky research we should encourage
young people to be creative to deviate
from dogmas and you know it's just very
depressing to me to see this behavior
and he's Young by the way so he wants to
show and see if he signs up because he's
looking for a job but this should not be
the climate
I agree I've often said you know there
was a guy in the in the 1850s who had
these incredible ideas that there is an
ether and that the space of the vacuum
was actually not a vacuum they're a
little gear years and whirlpools and
vortices and thank God for James Clerk
Maxwell that Twitter didn't exist back
then because he would have been
ridiculed and humiliated and we would
have thrown the electromagnetic laws
that are associated with his name 160
years later out with the bath water but
I think you're wrong Avi because I think
scientists are like children I mean we
don't play well with others we're very
jealous we like attention and we and we
don't like to share our toys right so I
want to ask Gary when uh when we see
things like this and Avi please you too
and I just want to remind everybody
we're talking about Avi lobe Gary Nolan
uh some of the most eminent uh
scientists who happen to have turned at
Great personal risk and I want to say
this with respect
um I don't have the courage that you
guys do I kind of do this because I
believe that we as scientists have a
moral obligation to share the data to
share the discoveries in a way that our
tax paying public who pay our freaking
salaries I don't care you guys are at
private institutions I'm at a public
institution but you guys are supported
by the public at a very deep level as
well I just want to put that out there I
feel it's my moral obligation to share
it but I don't have the courage to go
out on a limb to go on Tucker Carlson
like like Gary to go on the various
Outlets that that you've gone on as well
Avi because I I I'm worried I'm worried
about the the obviously there's there's
career risk Etc but there's also kind of
a intellectual capture that occurs when
when you believe something to be true
that no one else maybe agrees with you
or very few of your colleagues agree
with you it's a very lonely place and
I'm just saying in all honesty not many
scientists have that courage not many uh
people have that courage is the rarest
of all human emotions in my opinion so I
just want to express that but I do want
to say along the lines of data I've
heard people say and when Avi was on
with Eric Weinstein we heard things like
the data is ours it belongs to the
public I don't know if I necessarily
disagree that the data belongs to the
public but don't we have an obligation
as scientist Gary to interpret the data
are very complex someone who's watching
this channel may be a layperson very
bright brilliant I mean the smartest
audience in the universe watches this
channel but do they have the tools to
assess at the level that you do because
of your access because of the privilege
that you have to be a scientist can an
average layperson really understand what
it is that maybe you might be claiming
or is it your job to explain it in a way
that they could
does it belong I mean again this is kind
of a literally a riff on what
um on what Avi just said I don't think
of frankly what we're doing as
courageous I'm just doing what I thought
science was teaching me to do right and
that's really what Avi was saying is
that you know that that if if science is
about following rules that somebody else
wrote on stone tablets then science is
done right and so uh I've
spent my whole career doing things that
people told me shouldn't or couldn't be
done like when I was doing starting
companies back in the early 90s or mid
90s I was told you're gonna you know
destroy your career you shouldn't do it
now everybody does it right and people
people who used to come to me and tell
them I'm ruining my career come and ask
me how to start a company uh so that's
that's fine so I don't consider it I
don't consider it courageous I'm just
doing what I think we're supposed to be
doing
um you know that's the that's the first
part of it I'm sorry what was the second
part of your question
that you know when we see data for
example I'll hear it yes you know that
right how much you feel this data right
it belongs to the public NASA made the
Hubble Deep Field uh James Webb
Telescope but um it's a pretty picture
at one level right Avi it doesn't really
have a spectroscopic image so what level
do you have to have as a responsibility
Avi to instill it in a way that the
general tax paying audience who pays our
salaries at some level should understand
yeah so that's the rationale for the
Galileo project where we say we don't
need to wait for the government to
declassify data we'll just collect data
that we will open to the public so that
everyone can see it uh and we're funded
by donations and therefore we owe
nothing I mean there is no level of of
of secrecy the other thing I wanted to
mention very often uh funding is not
done from the private sector but from
committees that allocate federal funds
to researchers and these committees
argue we shouldn't take risks because
otherwise we will waste taxpayers money
well guess what if you were to ask the
taxpayers what do they care about more
the nature of dark matter being let's
say the lightest supersymmetric particle
or
whether we are alone or in our class of
intelligent civilizations in the Milky
Way galaxy they would say the latter and
if you don't want to waste taxpayers
money you should put it all in the
direction the taxpayers want it to be
spent and that poll was never made so
instead what you have is the mainstream
deciding on it on its own what's what
they believe is risky and as a result
they suppress innovation in other
directions and I say you know this
subject is different it's not just that
I'm deviating from the bitten path in
trying to pursue it it's the path that
the public cares about the most and that
will have a huge impact on the future of
humanity so by calling it thinking
outside the box we are missing the point
the box is in the wrong place I'm
thinking straight based on common sense
and one day my hope is the Box will be
placed when I'm exactly at the center of
that box okay but it takes time and that
happened to me multiple times in my
career where I just did what common
sense makes because after all I'm a farm
boy you know I was born on a farm I
don't feel that I'm that I belong to any
Elite uh even though I was chair of the
astronomy department at Harvard for nine
years you know I feel like the common
person I think straight I think with my
common sense I try to reflect what the
public cares about and my point is that
uh you know that's the way that science
should be done that we should be just
you know
pursuing what people care about instead
what you find in Academia is a lot of
acrobatics of people trying to show off
that they are smart and sometimes
they're going dark alleys that nobody
cares about like worrying about how many
angels can dance on the head of a pin
you know they equivalent of that would
be to say let's work for 50 years about
the notion of extra Dimensions without
evidence without evidence for
supersymmetry we invested the a lot of
billions of dollars in the Large Hadron
Collider we didn't find it okay my point
is it's not a bad thing to do that those
things but at the same time you
shouldn't ridicule study of something
that the public cares about that will
have huge impact and that so far was not
funded federally at all and why would we
even doubt that thing you know why would
we if we are doing we are sending
Interstellar props why wouldn't we
search for others that were sent in our
Direction in my view it's a completely
natural thing to do and the the
community is like 180 degrees away from
where it should be so it's the box that
is in the wrong place you know I'm not
thinking outside the box I'm thinking
what I you know is following common
sense if the box is out of the common
sense that's what I would argue I want
to ask you you know I want to throw it I
want to throw a bit of a stink bomb
though at Nasa if I may yeah go for it
um
this UAP
uh committee that they're doing the task
force several of those so-called
scientists and I'm going to call you a
so-called scientist until you prove
otherwise whoever I'm uh deriding here
have come out before they've even said
anything and done many of the things
before they've even done the analysis
and have done many of the things that
AVI has been discussing they've they've
pre-boxed their conclusions and
protected themselves against others
being who might uh uh say something
negative about them because of being
even on the committee how so how so Gary
well you know I think I can't remember
the name of the woman but she basically
came out and said something along the
lines of who we don't think that any of
this stuff is uaps and uh we're pretty
sure
not that Drake probably the the daughter
of Frank Drake
yeah I mean she made a statement and
then there was another person a a bu or
maybe it's uh he just came out this
morning he was just recently uh put on
uh the committee he said something
similar whereas like that what a sad sad
scientist you are that you feel that you
have to say something like that before
you even look at the data
um I'm I'm just I'm just disappointed I
I would take people like that off the
committee and I'll do something say
something else I think is a little
why is it only astronauts and
astrophysicists who are on this
committee why where are the other kinds
of scientists there's many other kinds
of scientists there actually is there's
Paula bontepe she's a biological
oceanographer there's an industry people
from uh from uh the biological
oceanographer
Institute of policy studies I agree
David grinspoon is a planetary
scientists
in tradition of a type of scientist that
I think
um has a predilection to not uh think
outside of the box or in the right box
um because they're more afraid of what
their colleagues might think than others
I I question the constituency of the
individuals who are on that committee
but but accepting that let's ask the
meta question Gary is this a good thing
is that is it in principle I mean we
shouldn't prejudge their conclusions
just as as you are now I'm happy I'll be
delighted if they prove me wrong okay
by the way I met with the committee and
had a very good conversation with them
the one thing that surprises me is not
what Gary just mentioned what surprises
me is that a year ago there was a
committee appointed by the City
community and decided not to have
discussions on UAP unidentified aerial
phenomena in any of the conferences
related to city now you ask yourself
Setia is supposed to be the closest Ally
to the study of objects that are unusual
okay uh why would they reject any
discussion and dismiss it up front not
allowing any discussion in their com in
their conferences and the only way I can
understand that is they want to distance
themselves from from those studies
because they want to show the rest of
the community that in fact they are in
the middle they are actually mediators
and they are more sane than another
group in their mind and as a result they
deserve funding and I find that that
apologetic tone to be completely
inappropriate we should search for radio
signals fine we didn't find any in 70
years just like waiting for a phone call
but we should also search our mailbox
for any packages that arrived and that's
a completely different method and I
don't see a contradiction and I don't
see why one is supposed to be considered
as less valuable or less worth pursuing
especially when the government comes out
and see and sees things they don't
understand so let's just figure it out
and why should the City Community be the
one to resist studies of UAP so I find
that really strange I must tell you
because it shows how the Dynamics of
Academia is controlled by societal
forces not biological thinking do you
think that they are under constraints
let's say they discover something you
know potentially transformative or
definitive proof that aliens don't exist
whatever that means okay no are they
under constraints because they they are
not gonna I've spoken with David spurgle
happens to be a personal friend of mine
um and he's not going to come on the I
mean he said he'd come on the podcast
but he has this thing called the US
Congress to testify in front of first
okay so that'll come down the line
Shelly writes uh my upstairs neighbor uh
UC San Diego so they they are sworn you
know to do a good job and come out these
results now on one hand we we have
talked about you know the the
fallibility or the or the implicit bias
that we have as human beings to confirm
or refute uh hypotheses that agree or
disagree with our preconceived notions
now I've heard a lot of say and there is
a substantial amount of Aviation and
space you know uh related people that
are on this uh including people from the
FAA
um I have heard a lot of things from
Pilots uh over the past couple of years
and I happen to be a pilot with uh with
instrument ratings and and all sorts of
of goodies that fly little tiny planes
around uh Southern California not far
from by the way where some of these Tic
Tacs and stuff were observed but uh I
want to get your impression first of all
Avi uh uh and then Gary uh for the
claims of of Commander David fraver you
know you you can't comment on their
braver I mean they're far braver and
they've done things that I'll never do
and I never criticized them you know
personally but we're you know we're very
skeptical of eyewitness evidence in a
courtroom why are we so you know willing
to believe in the Pro UFO UAP as alien
craft why is it so readily accepted that
the testimony of eyewitness who is
mostly trained to look at his
instruments and fly on his instruments
or her instruments um why do we take
that with outsized credulity Avi first
and then Gary I'd like to get your
impression I don't think it should be
regarded the scientific evidence now let
me first comment on why I think you see
the behavior of members of the committee
or others in seti and so forth there was
a congressman who expressed anti-gay
statements publicly when he was in
Congress okay and once he retired a
couple of years ago he confessed that he
is gay okay and what does it show you
about human psychology that very often
people are really intrigued by something
and they pretend to be something else
okay so because of what they see around
them and I think a lot of that is
happening in the context of UAP those
that are object to it the most are the
ones that are actually very intrigued by
them and by the way in religion very
often if you want to convert someone to
a religion those you know you target
those that object the most because they
care about it and then you realize you
can convince them so anyway just putting
that aside with respect to favor and all
these testimonies you know they are
intriguing they're fascinating and of
course we want to believe that there is
something else out there because it's
fascinating it's intriguing that it will
change everything but from a scientific
point of view I'll tell you too I'll
give you two scenarios that could
explain what the Nimitz report was about
one is there was a swarm of objects okay
so they saw an object at one point and
then a short time later it was behind
them now they say it moved so fast you
know that nothing can do that but in
fact it was two different objects that
came in and out of view and it was not
the same object so unless you have
scientific evidence you are dealing with
you know you can reel this read the
serial number of the object and tell
that it's the same object it may not be
the same object it could also not be a
physical object like if you have a laser
pointed at the you know and creating a
blob of hot gas that appears in your
infrared uh images and appears in your
radio images it may not be a real object
so we don't know maybe there was some
new equipment the government was testing
and not telling those who saw it uh the
point is that this is intriguing enough
for me or the Galileo project to build a
suite of instruments that we will employ
and bring to those locations and you
know monitor the sky take a video of the
sky in the infrared the optical the
radio and try to figure it out if if it
comes back again and we will of course
let everyone know and it will not be
eyewitnesses so the point of the matter
is this is good good enough to trigger
scientific inquiry it's not good enough
as scientific evidence
I agree I mean I call it like I said
before is preliminary data I could be
working at my bench or when I used to
work at the bench and I can see
something in the data uh that to me is
pretty clear evidence but I know that
there's a standard of proof that's
required to hand to others and so you
know if we could get all of the
necessary data from the fraver and the
other individuals maybe that could be
you know constituted as as actual proof
um but you know I so I think in in a nod
to the to the true Skeptics I don't mean
the the pseudo-skeptics and the
pathological Skeptics it's like yeah we
haven't done our job yet uh or the job
isn't we we don't have the necessary
access to do the job so I think what the
Galileo project is doing and uh is
exactly what needs to be done is just
you know let's take it into our own
hands and do it and if the government
wants to participate and have us help
that's a that's a great thing I mean one
other thing that I think is kind of
exciting though about this notion of um
let's say preliminary evidence or
whatever if if some civilization has
made it past the inflection point of
self-immolation that we are you know
seem to be on the precise of ourselves I
see that as a positive thing
um I I look at you know these supposed
events that people see in these objects
even if they're not real as as uh
as a horizon to which we can Aspire
right if something can do this or if we
if we force our minds to think well
can we do something like that that to me
is a is a fantastic uh way to excite the
younger generation to come up with new
ideas and new technologies even if
everything that uh is going on around
uaps ends up being to be a complete uh
and utter illusion well we're going to
take questions from the audience so I've
seen a couple of thousand uh comments go
by uh but I'm gonna start to start the
process now of actually looking through
them by taking my host prerogative and
just a reminder we're talking with
Professor Avi Loeb of a small
institution in Cambridge I love it when
I meet somebody from from Harvard Avenue
and they say I go to school near Boston
in Cambridge Massachusetts oh you really
you go to the Cambridge Institute of
virology
um I I will Define the the institution
as having smarter undergrads than many
faculty I know everywhere wow well that
is uh in contrain distinction to William
F Buckley Jr who said I'd rather have me
my government be comprised of the first
50 names in the Boston phone book than
the faculty of Harvard University but I
did I did once meet somebody who said I
go to the best university in the world
uh and I said oh yeah which one she said
I'll give you a clue it starts with an h
and ends with a D and I said Harvard she
said Howard are you crazy
um so that's a shout out to uh some of
my young colleagues
um Gary Nolan joining us from a Stanford
University
um AVI has some book news that I want to
share and first of all I put links to
both the gentlemen's web uh Pages down
in the in the description I put a link
to the paper that Gary referred to about
the wow signal and DNA uh but uh but in
particular avi's got a series of
articles in addition to his uh Smash Hit
book called extraterrestrial which he
for which he was on the show a year ago
or two years ago now I can't believe it
obvi it's going to be two years in
January and he's promised he'll come
back for his new book uh say a little
bit about your new book Avi yeah it's
called Interstellar and it will be about
the implications to humanity of
everything we discussed so stay tuned
for that I should say that um you know
over the past since my previous book
appeared I I was on about 1800 the
podcasts and interviews for TV and
newspapers and so forth but the biggest
satisfaction came about a week ago I
attended The Summit in Palm Desert and
um a woman came to me originally from
Iran and she said can I have a selfie
with you and I said sure she knew about
me and she took a selfie and then she
said that the following morning she said
I posted it on Instagram and there are
hundreds of Iranian women scientists
that wrote back to me and said that they
are following your work and I thought to
myself wow that's quite remarkable
because I'm originally from Israel and
I'd never imagined it would be hundreds
of Iranian women following my work and I
basically recorded a video a snippet
with her in which I supported the women
of Iran in their fight right now in the
protest so what I would like to say is
this subject resonates with a lot of
people around the world a lot of people
are excited about it we are going to do
the expedition to Papua New Guinea there
is a lot going on
every day I get a surprising things
happening uh and within a year or two I
bet you that we will have a conversation
landscape will change okay it's not up
to Federal institutions to authorize
progress It's not up to the dogma of
Academia to to tell us what reality is
like we will just figure it out like
kids and then you know I don't really by
the way I keep thinking about Galileo
that knew the truth about the Earth and
the Sun and was put in house arrest like
who cares whether the public knows about
it whether people don't like it you know
that's completely relevant if you know
what reality is like one way or the
other it will the news will break out
okay because that's the reality you can
hide the virus you can avoid people
knowing about it but the virus if it's
there people will get sick you know so
that the reality is whatever it is
irrespective of what humans try to do to
hide it and I like to look at the
pimples of reality I don't want any
makeup you see the people around me try
to put makeup on reality so it looks
better so that we are the only
intelligent you know uh civilization out
there we feel better about ourselves
this way I
to realize if there is a smarter kid we
want to learn from the smartest kid in
our class that's what we should aim at
because it will give us inspiration so
we want to find who is smarter you know
out there one reason I search for
intelligence in space is because I don't
often find it when I open the newspaper
Ryan Avi I can't resist uh you quoting
your your top uh your top aphorism from
last appearance when you're on with Eric
Weinstein I'll put a link to it what did
you say about the sky and being
classified Avi well the sky is not
classified and that's why we should look
at it you know and I think we're we
should think of ourselves as students of
nature let it let nature educate us
rather than having a monologue in which
we say what nature is supposed to be and
out of nature you know I grew up on a
farm and to me nature is the entire
universe okay and there is my so we are
focused most of the time on the
two-dimensional surface of this rock
that we were born on the the Earth but
it's it's it's just a tiny Rock in in a
huge space and and just you know let's
be more modest and and and look up
that's all I'm asking let's look up
let's check our mailbox like why are we
so close-minded you know like uh that
that is really and fermias 70 years ago
where is everybody that's so
self-centered like to stay at home and
say I don't see my neighbors you know
like what is going on here well you
didn't look through the windows you
didn't use a telescope back in 1950 uh
so how can you claim where is everybody
like well hopefully we'll we'll get a
lot of good packages in the mail this
Black Friday with uh books uh and um uh
so first question from the audience uh
for Gary uh comes from uh uh one of my
listeners uh who's asking are you
related to Christopher a uh and then in
all seriousness uh red panda koala asks
any updates on the Havana syndrome uh
and have you noticed any patterns in
experiences held by people that you've
encountered so Havana syndrome up
operated
I mean well the I mean I I mean the
Havana syndrome relationship
work for me basically was um you know
when we had a hundred individuals that
were you know the the some of the data
Medical Data was taken to me you know we
had back around 2014 2015 already
figured out that there were
um well we had called it at the time
interference syndrome we didn't know
that it was basically some sort of it
was related to the
um the uh the issues going on at the um
at the U.S embassy in Havana
those cases that I was involved with
with Havana have been handed over to the
US government they're not my I would say
that's a good thing they're not my
problem anymore you know science is
about classification and once we could
classify them as some kind of frankly uh
attack on our Diplomatic Corps or
individuals those individuals were then
taken out of my hands I mean not in a
negative sense just so I could hand them
over because they were classic they were
I could classify them as something other
than let's say UAP they weren't
interesting to me anymore because they
were understandable but what was left on
the table and I think is really this is
what the individual is is asking about
um are the individuals who were harmed
in some way or had damage uh who claimed
some kind of
UAP interaction again it's for for me
the the story of the UAP intervention is
less interesting to me than is the
damage that happened to them and how
they came about to be damaged and what
was the let's say the technology that uh
caused the damage and so I I tried I've
said this before I try to stay away from
the anecdotal aspect of the story
because I can't verify that but I can
look at the same x-ray or the same
medical analysis of an individual and I
can reproduce that analysis and so
that's where I'm I'm focused uh and I'm
sorry if that's not the kind of answer
that uh Mr koala wants but that's really
as far as I'm willing to go the other
thing I've said is I will not do science
by press release yes I will wait until
the science is vetted by other
individuals I got in big trouble doing
science by press release with that
so-called Atacama thing and that you
know was I the gentleman Stephen Greer
who I had speculated along the way that
I thought that some of the DNA results
looked odd and maybe it was an alien or
something but they what I found is that
if you speculate to the public who don't
know what the limits of speculation mean
they sometimes take what you're saying
as a conclusion and when I basically
published the paper showing that this uh
unfortunate mummy was in fact a young
girl likely born prematurely and had
multiple mutations in uh genes that were
um basically in bone development genes
and I had literally the world's expert
on bone development genes Ralph lockman
from here at Stanford three other
Stanford professors who were specialists
in South American genetics and all the
rest validate verify the results 13 or
14 post-docs graduate students Roche
science roast Diagnostics on the paper
Etc et cetera
and I published it it didn't matter and
all they could all they could basically
say was I was I somehow had convinced a
Cadre of 15 or so people to
to fabricate the data because I got a
grant from the dod
for doing ovarian cancer and that was my
payoff I I mean I mean that is literally
it's it's you know that's what I had to
go through and I realized okay you
really do the ethics of how science is
done really do work you have to stick to
the rules and the rules are
be very careful what you speculate uh
because the people who don't understand
the rules will run with it I mean we see
this in the newspapers and social media
every day so that's why I won't go any
further so I'm sorry red koala Panda no
that's okay Avi for you this comes from
uh Professor Brian Keating if you had
unlimited budget let's just say
unlimited what would you be doing what
what could you be doing and Gary I'm
going to ask you the same question what
would you do with effectively unlimited
budget I'm I'm tweaking this by the way
I tweeted to Elon Musk yesterday about
this very go ahead Abby yeah I should
note that this is not a hypothetical
question now I know I know it is okay so
uh because I'm I'm you know I I get to
meet a number of people that are quite
excited uh and many of them come to the
porch of my home to discuss it with me
so you know as I said the two-thirds of
Americans really care about and believe
in extraterrestrial life and uh you
might assume that many of the
multi-billionaires that became wealthy
recently are drawn out of that
population so many of them care about it
what would I do so um I would follow
um studies along three tracks which is
pretty much what the Galileo project is
doing just much more forcefully so one
track is um right now I have money to
perhaps
duplicate the system of instruments that
we have maybe a few times and put it in
three locations okay uh but if I get
tens of Millions or more than that I
will have I could have hundreds of those
systems and that is really the minimum
needed to study the problem thoroughly
and get enough statistics on all the
unidentified area phenomena that appear
during reports so what I need is a
factor of 10 in funding or more than
that and the more the better in the
sense that we know how to make those
instruments in fact this week is very um
sort of historic for the Galileo project
because For the First time we're getting
data from all the instruments and
bringing them to the computer systems
that we have and starting to analyze
with artificial intelligence algorithms
so we are as in the coming weeks we will
basically make sure that everything
works and then within a month or so we
can start planning where to put
additional copies of that Suite of
instruments and what I'm limited by is
the funding so if I get enough funding
let's say tens of millions to 100 100
million that would allow me to get to
the bottom of this question what are
unidentified aerial phenomena I can
promise that and we we can demonstrate
that we know what we are doing with the
current system we just need more copies
of it so that's one track the second one
is going after the fragments of
interstellar meteor so we are going to
Papua New Guinea to scoop the ocean
floor that's one Interstellar meteor
from 2014 the first Interstellar object
in the solar system tougher than iron
tougher than all the other space rocks
known and therefore it's possibly of a
some artificial alloy composition so we
want to find out by collecting the
fragments and we are fully funded for
that that's a one and a half million but
there is another Interstellar meteor
that we identified and we would like to
go after that as well so that's at the
level of a few million dollars we can go
after Interstellar meteors okay so we
have the Tens of millions or 100 million
for the UAP and at the level of Millions
for the Expeditions then the big ticket
item is really space mission so objects
that do not collide with Earth like or
more Wars we could come close to them
and take a close-up photograph and such
a mission is actually a billion dollars
in costs so we are thinking about
proposing uh to space agencies like NASA
or others uh but at first we are
designing the mission the parameters of
such a mission and we will have a dating
app the Vera Rubin observatory in Chile
that will start operations next year and
it serves as a dating app because we
will see more objects like and we will
swipe to the left for most of them but
some of them would look intriguing and
we would like to approach them as they
come towards us and perhaps take a
close-up photograph and that's the most
expensive if I had unlimited budget I
will have those uh you know space
missions that meet unusual Interstellar
objects just like and take a close-up
photograph maybe even land on them so
that they can tell whether it's a
hydrogen Iceberg a nitrogen Iceberg a
Dust Bunny in which case you would pass
through it these are the suggestions by
advertising billboard right yeah or they
have some screws and bolts and we can
land and I would love to press a button
if it's yeah well actually uh so Joe is
asking a question Joe Westcott is asking
he'd love to help out he's got a lot of
money because he donated uh 20 to bucks
to the Super Chat so I'm I'm expecting
he's also a billionaire so now I've had
on five billionaires on the podcast
um how can an ordinary uh stem
professional participate in the Galileo
project okay so we have two uh on the
Galileo website there are two uh items
one is how to contribute if someone
wants to contribute funds how to support
support us and the second is
volunteering to be part of the research
team and there is a different tab for
that and you just feel the fill the form
and we will look at your credentials and
make a decision
or you can contact me you can just email
me okay and uh yeah we'll have links we
have links to your website on the
comment section down below Gary if you
had unlimited funds say Phil Knight
decides to make another 400 million
dollar donation to that fair University
to let the Winds of Freedom Blow In This
research uh what would you do with
unlimited budget it's really kind of a
surreptitious question actually
well you know as as some people know
I've been interested in these claimed
materials that have been either Left
Behind or or dropped from these uh uaps
I mean there's there's an interesting
pattern where an object is seen and uh
it drops something and often a molten
metal in fact I published a
peer-reviewed paper on exactly this and
uh on a on a well credentialed uh event
um you know we didn't find anything
unusual but there in terms of the
constituency because it was a molten
metal but how does a molten metal end up
in the middle of a field uh where
everybody saw a glowing blinking object
you know just a few hours before
um so you know in in that vein and say
uh looking at things that for instance
Tom DeLonge says that he has or that
others might have there is there are a
range of scientific instruments which
could be brought to bear as well as a
couple that need to be built including
something called an atomic Imaging scope
that
um you know if if you have something how
do you prove that it wasn't made here
well you need to know that it was made
of things for instance that humans don't
normally make that's hard to say because
we can pretty much put any set of
elements in a in a vat mix them together
and and they'll be there but it's how
they're put together
um and if it isn't an obvious technology
nuts and bolts is obviously just alluded
to uh then um how do you understand or
how do you prove that it it is from
elsewhere
um but secondly let's say that you do
have something which is verifiably not
human and it is millions of years ahead
of us in in some manner or developed by
a technology or a civilization farther
ahead the next point of of just claiming
beyond what it is that it is from
somewhere else is what does it do and
how does it do it
and so you know if we're going to learn
lessons from our Bettors let's say uh
what better way to do it than to
understand the material that it's made
of and so as it turns out I have seen
data supposedly from inside of the
government on some of these supposed
materials
and I was left wanting for the kind of
analysis that were that was done it just
was insufficient
um and so there needs to be sort of a
standardized pipeline of how the data
should be how materials should be
processed so that you can compare apples
to apples oranges to oranges so at the
end of the day you get a report which
can be read by the scientific Community
to say one way or the other I just wanna
I just want to produce the data in a way
that is credible and then let the
conclusions flow from the data but I
have you know the the amounts of money
to create some of those to put together
a suite of such instruments is in the
tens of millions of dollars to do this
and to do the make the instrument that I
want to make uh you know I actually
turns out I have the funding for it now
uh but you're talking uh you're talking
a lot of money uh as well I mean
producing data is one thing analyzing
the data is wholly another right and so
you basically need to basically bring in
the the kinds of experts PhD and
otherwise to to do it I I can't do it
anymore I don't have the time yeah and I
mean looking at you know infinite
budgets I mean the government can
actually print their own money so in a
certain sense they have infinite budget
are you impressed with the budget
they've dedicated to date to this UAP
task force AVI or Gary
I'm I'm satisfied that they're putting
the money to it and so to the extent
that they actually do something with it
and don't come out with some you know I
I hope that they put a report out uh for
commentary before they finalize that
report uh I think I I mean that I think
would lend a lot of credibility to it
um so we'll see I'm I'm withholding
judgment and I would love to I would
love to say six months from now when
they're done with it I'm sorry to the
committee for insulting them okay uh
next up Avi this is for you uh you can
obviously comment on or whether or not
you think the sufficiency of the federal
government NASA budget is adequate do
you just comment on that quickly Avi
well we don't know what it will be
um the right now it's a study that was
funded at 100K and is supposed to
recommend within a year by June 2023 uh
how much money NASA should allocate to
the study of UAP so this is not really a
study of the nature of unidentified
object it's more about whether NASA
should invest in such a research uh and
therefore the funds will be allocated if
they are recommended only probably two
years from now if you think about it
realistically and my hope is that the
landscape of research on this subject
will change in the meantime because the
Galileo project for example will collect
data and
um so I you know I believe we should not
wait
uh for others to approve the research if
there are sufficiently wealthy
individuals that are excited about this
question we can do it ourselves we don't
need to wait for anyone you know it's
just like the play of Samuel Beckett
Waiting for Godot you can wait forever
either for the government to declassify
data or to fund things that you wanted
to find and then you realize that you're
actually the some of your colleagues are
blocking it because they want the same
funding for something else but however
if the funding comes from the private
sector and most of my funding came from
the private sector over the past decade
and I established a new center at
Harvard that unrelated to this subject
on black holes for example and all of
the funding comes from foundations or
private donations and my point is in
that case you can explore new
territories and you can pretty much
decide about what seems exciting what is
exciting to the public and I think
that's a much better path for Innovation
simply because of the reasons we
discussed before that there is a lot of
inertia for experts to claim that they
already know everything and they deserve
more prizes in addition to the ones they
already deserve and therefore no
knowledge should not be gathered because
it would threaten their status yeah so
comes in another question this is from a
a fellow farmer Avi Simon farmer who
asked the following question
um what criteria do you have established
to determine if you spot something
whether or not its design is terrestrial
human-made or not
oh it's very simple
um basically there are two categories of
objects that we are familiar with these
are human-made objects
or natural objects we all know about
airplanes drones satellites weather
balloons yes
um you know Rockets
um these are human made and we also know
about birds insects you know and uh
meteors that are Rocky and so the first
task is to basically see if everything
we find in the sky belongs to one of
these two and if we see an object
behaving in ways that are not
uh explainable as human-made technology
because we don't have that capacity you
know we pretty much know the limitations
of existing I mean either from Espionage
or from what we develop I mean all of
you know countries around the world are
not The Head and Shoulder above the U.S
so we pretty much know our limits and if
we see something behaving
technologically Farm you know better
than what we can produce then we know
that you know it's not us and at the
same time if we verify that it's not
biological it's not the natural uh then
we know that it's not from this Earth
okay so that's really uh now we still
don't know what it is so my point is it
will take a long time for through the
learning experience of figuring out what
it's seeking what kind of information is
trying to get how should we respond to
it uh and we don't have a protocol for
that there is no organization that
represents Earth because we never
imagined that we'll have a visitor in
our backyard or that we will find a
package in our mailbox you know if you
find a package in your mailbox that is
not sent by your family members but in
the home you know like send to just put
there by your kids or something
um if if it came from far away you know
you have to decide what to do with it
because you don't know what's in what's
inside and one way to figure it out
maybe is to try and and learn about it
what is it trying to do what is uh what
could be the content of this package and
and that would be a learning experience
we can use artificial intelligence for
that because it might be equipped with
AI itself you know so our AI systems
will have kinship to their AI systems
more than to us and that's the way I see
the future by the way I'm very proud of
our technological kids AI systems uh I
don't necessarily think about sending
humans to space I think about sending
technological gadgets that are equipped
with AI and so I think it would will be
a learning curve for us to figure out
what it is but at first the first step
is just to
find something that is not familiar okay
that's the first thing a follow-up
question from Anton's asks uh are you
going to open source the either AI or
the machine learning research data is
that going to be open source and he says
kaggle is a good platform yeah so okay
so we are currently developing it and we
are also starting to collect data
eventually the data will be public and
the tools that we use will be public so
people can check us and also do their
own work that's the way science is done
and we plan to follow that until you
know we verify that things work to our
satisfaction you know before that it's
premature we don't want to cry wolf and
you know for no good reason so we want
to actually verify that what we're
getting is is reliable we calibrate our
instruments we will test our algorithms
and we have already eight papers that we
submitted to the Journal of astronomical
instrumentation where we describe the
instrumentation that we are currently
already testing so we will be open as
open as possible that will be a breath
of fresh air into the subject because
people are used to secrecy or I mean
it's clear why the government has
classification because they collect the
data by sensors that that are classified
they don't want adversaries to be aware
of the capabilities of the US so it's
not so much the data it's the sensors
and if we developed our our own sensors
that are open you know off the shelf
then we have nothing to hide
next question comes from my friend Delon
Levy who asks
um Gary does the does or did the
government or some other earth-based
institution have a live alien and what
if anything did they learn about these
internal composition of such creatures
if such I I'm not deriding it and I've
you know I've seen fascinating you know
a fascinating movie moment of contact
from James Fox about uh some of these
kinds of events I don't know I've not
seen anything
um and uh so as sadly it's it it's
anecdote
um but I think there's a there's a
different kind of question that is being
asked here is how do you deal with
um the hundreds or thousands of
individuals uh and often uh children
their testimonies how do you deal with
the testimonies of individuals as as was
Bayesian priors uh you know how do we
deal with that kind of information
um and is it sufficient to get uh others
interested again there's different
audiences it's not sufficient for a
scientist as proof but maybe it's
sufficient for politicians
uh that it's worth
um you know at the very least I mean
John Mack from Harvard actually went
through exactly this is whether whether
what these people are seeing or not is
is interesting or real it does tell you
something interesting about the human
mind yeah I I would like to mention an
anecdote that I was asked by the Boston
magazine when they made a profile about
me
um a year ago that
um about what will happen if a
spacecraft landed uh in our backyard and
my wife said if they land back then she
said if they ever land and want to pick
you up just make sure that you leave the
car keys with me and they ask them not
to ruin the loan when they take off now
actually I was asked this question again
at the foreign public forum just a month
ago and I so when I came home I asked my
wife again I asked her did you change
your opinion and she said to me that
well this time I will tell you make sure
that you turn off the lights and I will
join you because she's a little bit
disappointed with what's going on around
the world now uh so you know there might
be an opportunity for us to stay
together even if I go on board I wonder
what the frequent fire mile situation
would you get you know alien Premier
gold or magnesium you get magnesium
status every what My worry is when I go
to Europe I see the same movie again and
again but if you go to Alpha Centauri
you'll have to see it millions of times
that that will be very boring well
unless unless it goes faster than light
Avi that's true that's true uh it's
because I'll be using the alcubiere
drive or some derivative yeah yeah Gary
uh mumfi which is which is one of the
names I chose for one of my kids
actually uh sends us a Norwegian
donation asking you Gary do you have an
update on the sphere you got from
colthart I don't coldheart well yeah
this is another
um
situation where you know somebody had
some anomalous I I won't go into the
into the details of it here but they
have an anomalous material and it's the
same thing I've said to to others is
um yes I have the I have the material no
I have not yet done the analysis because
I'm not going to do the analysis until I
have all of the right instruments lined
up
so that uh when I do it it's not just
it's just not a one-off data point it's
a one-off data point is useless it's
correlated to nothing and so um you know
as as I said it's expensive people don't
understand how expensive it it
yeah okay so I run it I'll I'll get iron
and maybe some chromium or whatever that
doesn't prove anything to anybody
yeah and so you know I just it's just
and even if I did if it were if it were
something worth uh you know uh
announcing I won't do it in a press
release I'll publish a paper probably in
a really boring place and let the world
deal with it from there because one data
point in isolation is nothing to me let
me ask you this question that that came
up in the context of a of a friend of
mine who was uh received I won't say too
much about it not to be you know
purposely mysterious but but just
because I don't know if it's anyway he
wanted to use some campus resources
um you know uh x-ray fluorescent
spectroscopy
Etc et cetera to look at some um uh some
ancient artifacts found uh in a
shipwreck and and this was uh you know
something that we could look at with
tools that we have here and he was even
willing to pay for it but the question
came up you know can you use you know
campus resources or even government do
you think you know you might face if if
you did get you know as part of your
reluctance to to kind of I mean
obviously you want to avoid being on
People magazine although I was just in
People magazine recently not for world's
sexiest man don't get your hopes up but
instead guys it was for a comment that
made about the sun uh but but anyway
um Gary speaking about that I don't know
if I mentioned to you but one day um
someone pointed out to me a tweet uh of
a husband who said his wife got she said
she has a crash of on an on a scientist
named avilo but who she thinks is sexier
than Anthony fauci and I mentioned it
immediately to my wife and her response
was fauci is a low bar
you guys should know you should be on
the borscht circuit I know well that's
our yeah we we Avi and Brian we we do go
on tour uh but Gary would you face
opposition for using you know do you
have to be totally privately funded
not at all
um first of all I mean I would I won't
use NIH funds to do things for you know
that are aren't uh validated but I have
an endowed chair yeah uh that you know
it basically generates a few hundred
thousand dollars a year that I can use
for anything I happen to be on very good
terms with the family uh that originally
donated the money that generates those
endowed funds for me every year they're
perfectly fine with me doing it
um and Stanford is perfectly fine with
me doing it because at the higher levels
uh at least he at least here they're you
know they understand that inquiry like
this is is uh laudable
um and if they ever dare to try to stop
me I would find ways to embarrass them
ominous that's uh good to know and I
don't want to get on your bad side Gary
and if you are related to Christopher
Nolan that could even be more impressive
okay we're going to ask uh some
existential questions of Gary I've asked
these to Avi but but actually I want to
get it's time for an update Avi uh it
was two years ago you were on the first
time on this podcast
um so I'll take a couple more questions
from the audience there's still time in
the closing minutes just a reminder
you're talking to uh professors uh Avi
Loeb good good friend of the show
four-time guest five time now on the
into the impossible podcast I have links
to his previous episodes along with all
the content I've had I've had on
Skeptics Gary you should know I've had
on Michael Shermer I've had on Mick West
these are people I don't know if you
want to comment on them but they've uh
they they are decidedly not on the UFO
as uh alien technology front well you
know that Michael Shermer is also a
member of the Galileo project and I
brought people from both sides because I
think evidence will eventually so it's
sort of like a litmus test if everyone
is united in the interpretation of the
data I know that we're not missing
something so I said the to so Michael
said that at some point
you know if you find evidence that is
conclusive I will be glad to write an
article about it in my magazine skeptic
and I told him uh you know that's not
enough I want you to change the name of
the magazine from skeptic to believer to
believer wow that's now you could play
the pope uh Abby we can really mix up
some Catholic and Judaism
um okay so uh just a reminder we're
talking Avi lobe of Harvard and Gary
Nolan of uh Stanford University and uh
and I'm Brian Keating your humble host
of the into the impossible podcast where
you've had um uh dozens of conversations
on this Most Fascinating subject and we
have another one coming up with Jacques
valet another uh introductory to me by
none other than Kurt J mungle Who's
lurking in the chat room and it's been
so kind to to introduce me to Gary and
uh and I want to thank him for that so
Jaco come on I'm trying to get Eric
Weinstein on with Jacques so let me know
give a thumbs up if you'd like to see
that pairing uh before the end of the
year okay and Gary maybe we'll have you
and Eric Weinstein that would be fun I
know he's interested to talk to you
Eric's a friend yeah that would be great
uh and he's also you know been paling
around with people like Lou Elizondo
lately so I want to get enough
um okay and and just a quick reminder if
you do want some Interstellar uh
meteorites you can uh uh sign up for my
mailing list briankating.com list and
you may win some extraterrestrial maybe
Interstellar I don't know I can't I
can't be sure uh but uh but maybe
we're all Interstellar that's right okay
so Gary you have not been on uh this
podcast but I love to ask the deepest
questions of life because a scientist
you know what they say about scientists
how do you know a scientist is outgoing
Gary because he looks at your shoes when
he talks to you
um uh but we have this Trope that we're
you know where these unhuman inhuman and
droidal you know kind of thinking robots
and and sometimes we deserve it right uh
we're we're on some kind of a spectrum
I'm so far on the Spectrum I'm off the
Spectrum but but uh but I do like to
humanize my guess and I'm not uh
implying that you're not human in any
way but I ask these questions and you
haven't really seen them I don't think
but but uh they really kind of relate to
the most important things of Life the
kind of meaning questions of life and I
want to start with something
that I asked Avi about when he was back
on the show and it's something in Hebrew
called a Zava ah it's an ethical will
not a material will and it has to do
with what you want to leave the planet
with in terms of your wisdom your
learning your your knowledge not your
material Goods which you know I don't
know where those will go but what wisdom
would you most want to communicate to
all of humanity and your ideological
errors once you spring forth this Mortal
coil as The Bard said
hmm
um well I I mean these are in some ways
trite but give more than you take
um and you know less than you think you
do uh and listen more
to others that the observations will
teach you more than anything you think
you understand I mean I I mean that's to
me what I was always brought up as give
more than you take
um and uh and frankly if you can take
nothing
beautiful and leave no Trace right now
it's all backpacking uh Avi did you want
to comment yeah so I actually met with a
class of undergrads at Harvard then a
couple of weeks ago and my advice to
them was um drawn from the metaphor of
walking on the beach you know you often
see some seashells that they maintain
you know unique colors and and structure
and then these are the the youngest
those that were swept ashore very
recently but those that over time were
robbing against each other as a result
of being dragged by ocean waves they
eventually lose their unique colors and
become you know break up into
indistinguishable
grains of sand okay so my message to the
young people is don't rub against each
other on social media too often because
then you will lose your unique colors
and and I I want people to maintain it
and you know when I was a young kid I
grew up on a farm and that taught me
that the independent thought is most
important in life because very often
humans are swayed by wishful thinking
that that's very common and if you want
to find your truth you should not seek
it in others you should look for it
yourself and keep your unique colors
don't surrender to how many likes you
have on Twitter and besides Twitter may
go away so yeah I mean if uh if Elon
keeps up with his pace of innovation
although I'm trying to get him you know
to spend a tenth of what he bought
Twitter for on some uh it's a
transformational physics project so
something's happened to your sound uh-oh
uh what about now can you hear me now
yeah there it goes okay good
um so the next question has to do with
and by speaking of Twitter you can
follow Gary Gary P Nolan on Twitter and
uh Avi is to uh his time is too precious
so he's not on Twitter but the Galileo
project has a Twitter account it is
Galileo project one on Twitter and
hopefully it will have a blue check mark
if they can come up with the eight bucks
from one of avi's billionaire buddies
okay next question for you guys
uh the namesake of this podcast uh dates
to the man whose Center we have at UCSD
the Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination and I am the associate
director of that fine August institution
and of course we open the audio podcast
which you can subscribe to as well with
sir Arthur's actual reading of the
following statement any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic
and I want to ask you if you had access
Gary to a monolith an object of great
permanence that could last not just 120
years billions of years into the future
what would you put on it or in it to
bespeak of the magical technology that
human beings have been able to construct
in our short few hundred thousand years
as a species of homo sapiens what most
majestic magical thing in your field
maybe you created or somebody else
created would you put on a monolith to
give a little Swagger to humanity oh I
was going to say a Rubik's Cube but um
uh let's see well I think one of the
most amazing devices that we've created
well I mean
but I I think any the lens
right because it's uh you know the the
Glass Lens it's a you know it's
emblematic of looking deeper right it's
kind of I mean beyond the wheel uh it's
probably one of the first devices we
ever created that allowed us to look
Beyond ourselves
and and that to me is uh you know
perhaps the best that's great it's
interesting that Gary is thinking in my
direction because the lenses are often
used in astronomy uh but my preference
would be to put the artificial
intelligence
uh so that um especially a system that
can evolve and learn machine learning uh
because then it will be dynamic and
whoever finds it will interact with it
and learn much more if we store enough
information in fact I was advocating in
a recent paper putting a
um you know a reboot system on the moon
that will be if something catastrophic
happens on Earth we want to keep all the
precious information out there and so I
bought a laptop over the summer and
together with it I had a backup system
the small tiny disk like system that
keeps all the information so the same
thing we can keep on the moon and
basically communicate to it by by laser
and transmit all the DNA information
about all life forms on Earth so that
it's stored there and all human
Creations all the music all the books
and so forth so that's sort of a
monolith because it keeps all the
information but I will add to that an AI
system that is able to use that like you
know what you use when you Google
something you know that's an AI system
and uh so that would be fun to interact
with yeah no I agree I just uh I put a
CD-ROM you know when I did this and
unfortunately you know the Microsoft
paper clip could not decipher the CD or
anyway I'm just joking guys uh okay last
two questions for you distinguished
gentlemen actually have to deal with
another quote from Sir Arthur C Clarke
which is the following he said when a
distinguished but elderly scientist I'm
not calling you guys elderly okay come
off it one of distinguished but elderly
scientist states that something is
possible he is almost certainly right
but when they State something is
impossible they are very probably wrong
Gary I want to ask you with all humble
respect and admiration what have you
changed your mind about what have you
been wrong about
well I don't know that I'm right or
wrong about it but I'm more of the
opinion that the universe is somehow
designed
or made for life
um you know maybe that's just my lack of
appreciation of of uh of the
possibilities but I I I am more of the
opinion that
the universe is uh is somehow
constructed to enable life now it could
just be that that's the way it is but
um it's easy enough to also imagine that
some larger entity uh you know in a
universe beyond us uh you know and we're
encapsulated within that you know
created conditions such that we are here
I just find it fascinating that the way
that all of the objects that operate
down at the fundamental units of of
nature uh can come together in a way
that allow for life I mean I'm in I'm in
a greater level of awe about it if
anything and if odd equals a religious
sort of uh consideration then that's
kind of where I am let me connect to
that
um so when I started astrophysics that
was 35 years ago uh there was this
notion that the early universe is simple
simply because we don't have data on on
it that many people said that oh
cosmology is simple you know just
because we haven't gathered enough data
and once we collect the data we will
find that it's as complex as the
universe nowadays full you know the
universe now has you know in addition to
life it has stars it has galaxies very
complex structures now as we got more
data about the early Universe now we
have a lot of data it's still simple
now this explains the error of time okay
because the universe started simple and
you can ask why and you know some people
advocate for Cosmic inflation that they
created initial conditions that are
quite unique and simple you know the
universe was pretty much uniform except
for small fluctuations some of us are
not sure that Cosmic inflation took
place and maybe some other process did
it the bottom line is the universe
started simple and became complex and
you know if you think about them you our
life it also goes that way we start
simple you know as babies and then we
get more complex as adults but here is
the catch complexity doesn't continue
forever okay because eventually we die
and we become really simple once again
so if you look at old people in a way
they are as vulnerable as babies and
they eventually become simple because
they end up dead and so um the same will
happen to our universe now it's sort of
at the peak of its complex electricity
maybe it will continue for a little
while but eventually we will be
surrounded by vacuum because the
expansion is accelerating and there will
be only our galaxies surrounded by
nothing because the ex all the other
galaxies will exit from our Horizon and
that's a simpler State okay and
eventually all the stars will die that's
a simplest State than we have now and
life will not exist so my point is we
are used to complexity increasing with
the era of time there will be a point
where Simplicity will increase with the
era of time so it's not always true that
era of time is in the direction of
increasing complexity and that's all
because of gravity you know that drives
everything in in ways that we do not
expect from thermodynamics
well guys this has been fascinating and
delightful speaking of inflation I wish
you both uh much inflation of your
waistline although Avi you're wasting
away I I used a picture you know of Avi
from like a year or two ago and uh I had
to take it down because you've you've
lost considerable number of kilos which
I will be conserving those kilos because
you and I are in an exchange where I
gain the weight you I I've not been so
kind in the past since the pandemic
started every day like for three years
actually I've been jogging at Sunrise
and I must tell you it makes me younger
I feel really great about it and it
increases the density of
thoughts per unit mass in my body
[Laughter]
Gary do you have a quick one two second
uh daily routine something important to
you or weekly routine that's that's
important to you uh
weekly routine
um well I work in my garden I have a
greenhouse I collect carnivorous plants
because what mad scientists you know
shouldn't collect carnivorous plants as
well as being interested in uaps I've
been interested in that sort of stuff
you tweet about that yeah
well a gentleman it's been a distinct
honor for me and I know from my audience
and I hope we can have many more
conversations like this as new evidence
new data arises and as you guys continue
also in your storied careers uh Avi
you've had a paper out recently about
disconfirming inflation I want to have
you back on for that as well as for your
new book Interstellar which I put up the
uh the the monograph the cover of it on
the screen a couple of uh maybe an hour
ago now Gary I want to have you back on
talk about all sorts of exciting
projects you're involved with get your
opinions on hot topics like crispr Gene
editing artificial life in the lab and
other things so hopefully you'll do me
another honor come back on someday yep
happy too thanks so much for now
everybody thank you so much for joining
the podcast and reminder we'll have on
Jacques valet hopefully soon maybe with
uh or without Eric Weinstein and we'll
hopefully have Gary and Avion many many
times uh to come so please do subscribe
and if you do want to win a chunk of
interstellar space Schmutz I'm shaking
it here these are actual meteorites 4
billion years old at least found in
Argentina about uh 500 years ago you can
enter to win your chance at Brian
keaton.com list and I'll send some to
you guys maybe a carnivorous plant and
uh and then for one lucky winner I will
send you some Uranus soap to keep your
anus clean everybody enjoy Thanksgiving
if you're in America if you're in Canada
I hope you enjoyed it last month like
Kurt my friend my good friend Curt John
Mungo I hope you enjoyed your
Thanksgiving I hope you all have a
wonderful uh holiday season coming up
and stay tuned to the into the
impossible podcast bye everybody